too bad it's not tonight of course
people are working i don't know that you
can do eight to midnight on a weeknight
but uh yeah so we'll
we don't want to you know we don't want
to spoil the party but we want you to be
prepared for sure for friday night we do
have clouds out there making for a
gorgeous sunrise this morning not much
wind i mean you can see the palm fronds
they are barely moving around on top of
the red rock casino resort camera out
there on the west side 84 on the strip
sunrise mountain
summerlin 81 83 at mountains edge 85 at
centennial hills aliante about the same
red rocket 77 mid 80s also for henderson
right now we've got some slightly cooler
temperatures once you get over to
kingman at 75 up to cedar city 59 this
jacket weather this morning mid 60s for
cali any closer to the valley 75 in
indian springs 80 in perump on the back
side of the spring mountains and some
mid 80s for boulder city and sandy
valley with those mid 90s still for
death valley mount charleston the
mountains will be the focus of
thunderstorms today just a little lift
to daytime heating in the higher
elevations so we're looking for mid 70s
up there for highs and that chance of
thunderstorms definitely greater up
there we're only looking at a very very
slight chance this is just a break
there's just not much instability in the
air there's plenty of moisture around
but we get another surge of monsoon
moisture that will be coming up from
mexico later tomorrow
into friday yes and that's going to
bring back the chances for a widespread
thunderstorms to finish off the week so
we did have some thunderstorms in the
mountains and to the southeast of the
valley and then one little bitty cell
right there right around dinner time
dropped a little bit of rain not a whole
lot a little bit
as we widen the picture and look at the
the whole country showers and
thunderstorms across the great lakes
heading into the western ohio valley and
this is all that heat and humidity that
is still focusing over the central
plains the mid-south back over into
kentucky and that terrible devastating
flooding so many people are cut off by
all those washed out roads and the
flooding the high water still and
without power now they've got to deal
with temperatures in the upper 90s and
humidity is so high heat indices well
over 100 degrees 102 today for us that's
where we were yesterday and very very
slight chance of an isolated
thunderstorm but again better chances
for the mountains now that monsoon surge
brings back a 30 chance of storms
tomorrow afternoon and evening and a 50
percent chance of thunderstorms on
friday and those could last into the
nighttime hours slight chances left for
the weekend temperatures fall back into
the 90s that's the trade-off you trade
heat for humidity and vice versa